ja was ich hier mache ist längst zu
einem volkssport geworden herzlich
willkommen
fitness körperkult ernährung schönheit
heute scheint sich fast alles um unseren
körper zu drehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja unser körper ist zum kunstwerk
geworden das zumindest behauptet mein
heutiger gast jörg scheller ist
professor für kunstgeschichte an der
zürcher hochschule der künste und
praktizierende experte für heavy metal
musik ebenso wie für bodybuilding
herzlich willkommen hersteller freue
mich da zu sein
ja das hier ist für sie wahrscheinlich
ein kinderspiel das auf alle fälle ein
alltagsgegenstand mit dem ich häufiger
in berührung komme mit fünf kilogramm 5
kilogramm ist auf alle fälle ein gewicht
mit dem man sich gut aufwärmen kann
was machen sie damit man könnte damit
zum beispiel die schultern ein bisschen
aufwärmen durch seiten seit eben machen
könnte die rotatorenmanschette damit ein
bisschen stimulieren
man könnte damit den oberen rückenmuskel
auch durchaus funktional bearbeiten also
da gibt es relativ viele möglichkeiten
man hört und sieht schon sie sind öfters
ein fitnessstudio viermal die woche
wie das aussieht champions ganz kurz an
[Musik]
ja ziemlich eindrücklich für mich warum
tun sie sich das an
neuer für einen echten bodybuilder wäre
das nicht möglich eindrücklich für den
kunsthistoriker es ist vielleicht ganz
okay bei den bodybuildern geht es
natürlich um sehr viel mehr warum ich
mir das antue es kann ich ihnen nicht
genau sagen bei mir war es so dass ich
alter von 14 15 jahren von einem
physiotherapeuten ins fitness center
geschickt wurde und eigentlich aus dem
grund dass sich eine haltung schwäche
hatte und im fitnesscenter begegnete ich
menschen die mich fasziniert haben das
waren aber nicht die fitness sportler
sondern das waren die bodybuilder und
diese faszination die hat eigentlich bis
heute angehalten
nico ist das suchtpotenzial der
suchtpotenzial ist wie bei sehr vielen
anderen tätigkeiten groß aus dem
suchtpotenzial sehe ich auch in der
kunstgeschichte und lässt mich auch
nicht los ich lese wenn sie so wollen
ständig kunsthistorische bücher könnte
das als in form von sucht bezeichnen
ich glaube suchtpotenzial hat man ja
überall wo man sein wachstumspotenzial
sieht etwas was mit intensität zu tun
hat was mit ritualen zu tun hat
insoferne suchtpotenzial ist absolut
gegeben aber es ist absolut nicht
zwingend aber viele immer mehr menschen
machen es ihnen nachtun es ihnen gleich
gehen ins fitnessstudio fitness ein
körpertraining es zu einem megatrend
unserer zeit geworden was suchen all die
menschen da im fitnessstudio
ja ich kann als kunsthistoriker
natürlich keine psychologische
begründung geben
als historiker erstmal sagen es ist
nichts neues
das beginnt im neunzehnten jahrhundert
ist eine folge von urbanisierung von
industrialisierung diese folge davon
dass menschen vermehrt sitzende
tätigkeiten ausüben und eine
kompensation brauchen und da legen ärzte
wie zb gustav zander schon in den 90 68
18 70er jahren los kreieren maschinen um
den körper wie
in form zu bringen nein ich so seit
dieser zeit seit der zweiten hälfte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts boomt fitness
und bodybuilding kamen dann noch dazu
auch schon seit circa 1900 mit arnold
schwarzenegger jane fonda und so weiter
gab das dann massen trend sollte
nachkriegszeit also wir sprechen hier
von einem sehr sehr langen zeitraum und
von nichts was ich erst gestern oder
folk ist und ereignet trotzdem hat man
das gefühl dass dieser fitness trend
heute so was wie religiöse züge hat also
der gang ins team ins fitnessstudio ist
für viele vergleichbar mit dem gang in
eine kleine kirche wo sie sich irgendwie
die rituale finden und so weiter ist das
eine art ersatzreligion für viele
abgebrochen ich würde es nicht
ersatzreligion nennen gibt es kein
transzendent das wesen zu dem mann betet
oder einen sinn horizont jenseits dieser
welt aber strukturell ähnelt das gym
tatsächlich einer kirche
das ist erstmal ein ort der streng
geordnet ist es ein ort in dem ich mich
orientieren kann
wenn ich irgendwo auf der welt eine
katholische kirche gehe
dann weiß ich ungefähr wie ich mich dort
zurecht finde ich kann ungefähr
identifizieren welche elemente wo zu
finden sind mit dem gym verhält es sich
ganz ähnlich ich kann überall auf der
welt in einen schirm gehen ich werde
immer ungefähr mit dieser maschine kann
ich den bizeps bearbeiten wie diese
maschine kann ich den trizeps bearbeiten
usw
jim ist dass man mit dem begriff dass
philosophen michel foucault vielleicht
als hetero topi bezeichnen könnte
es ist ein ort der aus der üblichen
ordnung ausbricht
ein ort in dem tatsächlich eine ordnung
herrscht die wir anderswo nicht mehr
finden also viele menschen empfinden ihr
leben als chaotisch als reiz überflutet
als sehr komplex dass jim verspricht
eigentlich eine form von ganz strenger
wenn sie so wollen maschinelle ordnung
und ist damit einen raum der
tatsächlichen gegen raum zu den üblichen
räumen in denen wir uns
bewegen darstellt das ist etwas was da
zähle ich vielleicht mit dem religiösen
raum vergleichbar wäre
nicht zuletzt auch mit blick auf die
strengen ritualisierten tätigkeiten dort
ich kann im gym ganz kontrolliert
diszipliniert ritualisiert ange arbeiten
niemand redet mir rein da gibt es quasi
kein chaos kaum kontingents und auch das
ist etwas was viele menschen glaube ich
fehlt was in anderen orten vermissen
und das kann man im gym tatsächlich
erreichen aber ist man macht er da keine
spirituellen geistigen übungen sondern
körperliche das ist glaube ich ein
missverständnis ich würde so weit gehen
zu sagen dass es im gym eigentlich nicht
um den körper geht es geht nicht um das
fleisch es geht nicht um die materie um
was es im gym geht und in vielen formen
von fitness bodybuilding anderen körper
zentrierten praktiken ist die form
es geht ja darum in form zu sein
also wenn sie so wollen geht es sogar um
etwas sehr religiös nämlich um eine form
der eigentlich überwindung oder
disziplinierung des fleisches
also ich sage dass im wert neutralen
sinne nicht als ich das gut finde ich
persönlich liebe auch das absurde ist
eine abseitige an bodybuilding aber
tatsächlich ist das ganze ja keine feier
dieses gegebenen körpers also dieses
dieses fleisches in dem und mit wir dem
mit dem wir da erleben sondern es geht
tatsächlich darum an jeden zentimeter
des körpers zu formen die form im
philosophischen sinne ist ja das
geistige die form ist das was der idee
und dem ideal am nächsten kommt
immateriell leben
insofern könnte man sagen die bilder
sind eigentlich duschen durch
vergeistigte wie sehr schön und so was
wie künstler auch könnte man sagen also
wie ein wild aber der ansicht an sich
arbeitet an seinem erscheinungsbild ja
also ich würde sagen dass bodybuilder
tatsächlich ob sie das explizit zu sagen
und zu empfinden so meinen oder nicht
künstler sind zumindest bildhauer sind
denn sie arbeiten ja am körper wie an
einer statue und es hat arnold
schwarzenegger in den 19 70er jahren
auch selbst gesagt dass er er arbeite an
sich als sei er eine statue als sei er
ein bild haben und das ist eigentlich
eine neuzeitliche idee das ist eine idee
der renaissance die es um 1500 entsteht
ganz prominent bei pico della miranda
italienischen renaissance philosophen
der in seiner rede über die würde des
menschen sagte mensch steht einig in der
mitte der schöpfung ist ein unbestimmtes
wesen zwischen gott und theater gott und
er kann in alle richtungen gehen und das
ist der grund warum menschen frei sind
weil sie frei sind beginnen sie an sich
zu arbeiten
jetzt kann man ein bisschen grob sagen
so in der vormoderne wurde diese arbeit
eher religiös geistig aufgefasste ging
es um die moralische ethische veredelung
in der zunehmend materialistischen
moderne verlagert sich diese arbeit eben
auch auf den körper und insofern ist
bodybuilding tatsächlich so etwas wie
eine kunst einigte der selbst formen als
eine kunst sich selbst nicht als etwas
gegebenes zu begreifen sondern sich zu
transformieren
das kann man wunderbar darüber streiten
ob das original ist ob das sinnvoll ist
ob das schöne ist etc aber ganz nüchtern
betrachtet ist es eine kunst der selbst
formung die manche als wichtig und
richtig empfinden und von denen andere
sagen um gottes willen kann man die
energien denn nicht sinnvoller verwenden
aber schon beachtlich dass ich so viel
dass heutzutage eben auch wenn es
optimierung ist jetzt um den körper
dreht auch der ganze ernährungs habt die
körperpflege schönheit und so weiter wie
sonst sind so sehr fixiert auf diesem
körper
darum ist das so weil wir es nicht sein
müssten also vielleicht das ist mit dem
körper ja tatsächlich wie mit der kunst
kunst hatte in der vormoderne relativ
klare funktion und hat sie gebraucht zur
unterweisung zu propagandazwecken zur
verklärung des fürsten
zur ausstattung von kirchen um 1800
bricht es langsam weg und die kunst ist
eigentlich frei das heißt sie kann alles
mögliche sein aber sie wird im
eigentlichen sinne nicht mehr wirklich
gebraucht jetzt brauchen wir natürlich
unsere körper weiterhin um zu leben das
ist ganz klar
aber wir brauchen sie eigentlich nicht
mehr für die physische arbeit wir sitzen
hier an diesem tisch und so verbringen
der uns die meiste zeit unseres lebens
sprechen über den körper getippten
welche lustigen boote in computer ein
aber der körper hat eigentlich diese
notwendigkeit als arbeitsinstrument
verloren und das heißt weil er nicht
mehr in diesem zweck logischen
eingebunden ist in denen er früher
eingebunden war können wir ihn zudem für
ästhetische zwecke benutzen also weil er
nicht mehr diese klare funktionalität
hat und das finde ich ist eigentlich ein
relativ logische konsequenz der
modernisierung und der hand körperlich
auf die entkirchlichung prozesse der
moderne reagieren wir durch verkörperung
prozesse
wir arbeiten mit dem körper wie
inszenieren den körper wir präsentieren
den körper teile ihn nicht mehr in der
fabrik verschließen weil wir nicht mehr
auf dem feld verschleißen also ist eine
kompensation gegenbewegung gegen einen
gesellschaftlichen trend der moderne
das könnte man vielleicht auch so deuten
dass man sagt heute leben wir in einer
welt wo wir sehr wenig kontrollieren
können
in einer komplexen welt wo wir nichts
mehr du wirklich bewirken können
zumindest sehen wir nicht was wir
bemerken und beim körper ist das noch
ganz anders da können wir noch genau
steuern und durch ernährung durch durch
krafttraining sehen was wir bemerken
wirken mit unseren handlungen nach dem
würde ich zustimmen
glaubte der körper ist sozusagen das
letzte risiko um wo wir noch irgendwo
kontrolle haben und das ist sicherlich
einer der gründe warum menschen ins team
gehen wenn ich im gym an mir arbeiten
dann arbeite ich an mir gearbeitet
niemand sonst und wenn ich einen erfolg
verzeichnen
wenn der bizeps wächst dann weiß ich das
habe ich erreicht nicht person iks nicht
person y sondern das ist quasi mein werk
ist anders im teamsport das ist anders
im mannschaftssport wo ich eingebunden
bin eben auch in seine komplexe
konstellation wurde zu fall eine sehr
große rolle spielt all das habe ich im
team nicht und insofern haben wir auch
da wieder diesen religiösen aspekt
religion war ja immerhin versuchen
wissen was die zufälligkeit aus der welt
heraus zu interpretieren
da gibt es eben einen plan gibt es einen
gott da gibt es einen sinn nicht nur
einfach kontingents zu fall und insofern
ja absolut ich hätte man so weit gehen
und sagen körpertraining ist eine
ersatzhandlung man möchte ja nicht die
welt verändern etwas bewirken aber
stattdessen geht man jetzt eben
ja ich möchte mal die statistik sehen
die beweis dass menschen die ins gym
gehen weniger die welt verändern weniger
aktivismus betreiben um weniger ich weiß
was unternehmen gründen ich glaube die
rechnung geht nicht ganz auf das ist
auch so ein massen mediales narrativ
also training jim live das reform von
eskapismus
man muss genau hinschauen wer das glaube
ich nicht also ich sehr viel zeit in
james verbracht in sehr vielen ländern
ich habe sehr viele unterschiedliche
menschen in james kennen gelernt also
quer durch alle gesellschaften durch
alle gesellschaftsschichten wenn sie in
zürich ins david timm in schlieren gehen
dann treffen sie da den millionär und
sie treffen auszubildende sie treffen
menschen aus dem prekariat und sie
treffen migranten post migranten
alteingesessene schweizer also das ist
tatsächlich eine sehr breite spektrum
dass man dort vorfindet und die leute
kommen mit unterschiedlichen
motivationen und bei manchen geht es zum
beispiel darum tatsächlich ausdauernder
belastbarer zu werden für eine bestimmte
tätigkeit die eben nichts mit dem zu tun
hat denn nichts mit fitness bodybuilding
zu tun hat während das andere gibt bei
denen bodybuilding und fitness
tatsächlich selbst weg sind und in
diesen menschen sehe ich da durchaus
nachfahren von künstlern die sagen ich
mache kunst um der kunst willen la polar
geht es auch so ein bisschen um eine
innere stärkung vielleicht bei manchen
dass man sagt irgendwie man kompensiert
eine innere schwäche durch durch diese
äußere stärke ist eine steigerung des
selbstwertgefühls trägt diesen effekt ja
absolut ich finde nur diese innere
schwäche ist ja eigentlich der
normalzustand aus dem menschen die nicht
sehen dass wir alle schwach gewesen sind
dass wir verlässliche wesen sind das wir
fehlerhafte wesen sind die haben finde
ich ganz grundsätzlich ein problem
insofern natürlich man reagiert reagiert
auf eine form von defizit empfinden in
vielen fällen nicht in allen fällen und
versucht dem etwas entgegenzusetzen
und da sehe ich was die krafttraining
kraftsport fitness bodybuilding als
einen weg unter vielen das zu tun
ihr könnt natürlich auch professor
werden für astrophysik auch das wird ihr
selbstwertgefühl heben auch das wird
ihnen neuen status geben wo der sie
können sie umgehen und sie können sich
den monumental bizeps an antrainieren
wie gesagt die haltungen auseinander war
es jetzt wichtiger
und richtiger ist arnold schwarzenegger
hat immer betont dass das was er im gym
gelernt hat beim bodybuilding beim
trainieren auf andere lebensbereiche
übertragen konnte
und das ist glaube ich etwas da trennt
sich so lang die die spreu vom weizen
natürlich kann ich ihm gem versauern und
ich kann mich da zurück ziehen und das
wirklich eskapistische machen oder ich
kann im gym lernen ich kann versuchen
das was ich dort erfahren habe zu
transferieren in andere lebensbereiche
also mir zum beispiel hat durch diese
monotonie das ritualisierte im gym
geholfen konzentrierten ausdauernd zu
schreiben
ich kann mich hinsetzen und die scheibe
zwei stunden ich mache das einfach ich
denke nicht sollte ich könnte etwas
anderes machen sondern so wie ich ein
trainingsprogramm im gym absolviere
schreibe ich dann auch mal den text
sie haben ganz viel geschrieben unter
anderem ein buch ihre promotion ihre
doktorarbeit über arnold schwarzenegger
es jetzt sie haben uns gesagt dieser das
kann man übertragen was man da lernt den
schimmel ist es oft so dass es wie ein
qualitätssiegel ist oder ein
statussymbol ein trainierter körper dass
man zeigt man hartz disziplin man kann
an sich arbeiten ist belastbar
absolut das ist ganz stark geworden im
paradoxerweise nicht in diese nennt
körperliche zeiten in dem wir eigentlich
leben man sich die industrie die
arbeitsverhältnisse anschaut
tatsächlich ist der körper heute ein
statussymbol
also mit dem mann aus weißt ja ich achte
auf meine gesundheit ja ich bin
belastbar ja ich bin disziplin hervor
von kommunikation absolut genial und das
ist etwas was mich überhaupt nicht
interessiert weil das ist etwas das ist
für mich sein körper spießertum das hat
mich nie interessiert und deswegen haben
mich im fitnesscenter die bodybuilder
beeindruckt weil es gab im fitnesscenter
sich damit 15 jahren zum ersten mal war
gab es grob zwei fraktionen im es gab so
die sport gesundheits fraktion die im
futter belaste
schlanker ausdauernder gesünder und so
weiter werden wollte und es gab diese
für den jugendlichen die mich damals
eigentlich unheimlich und verstörend
wirkende bodybuilder bei den bodybuilder
geht es eben nicht um gesundheit geht es
eben nicht darum so ein was ist schöner
neoliberaler flexibler mensch zu werden
sondern die trainieren sich körper an
die eigentlich absurd sind wir sind
eigentlich absurd gehabt kann sich kaum
noch bewegen ja also das schenkt ein
dieser körper man hat mit diesem körper
außerhalb der bodybuilding community
eigentlich keine vorteile also kein chef
wird sagen herr borchert jetzt haben sie
50 kilogramm muskelmasse aufgebaut
fantastisch da stelle ich sie eine
befragung ja was passiert eigentlich nie
auch auf dem partner markt steigen ihre
chancen nicht zwingend wenn sie jetzt
irgendwie so ein 30 kilogramm
muskelmasse ja noch draufgepackt haben
also das geht alles nicht auf insofern
da gibt es die bodybuilding subkultur
die eigentlich bis heute eine subkultur
geblieben ist aber warum ist gibt es
fitness mainstream neben die
psychologische erklärung kann ich kann
ich nie geben bodybuilder sind
tatsächlich erstmal menschen die
unabhängig von der individuellen
psychologischen verfasstheit nach
intensität streben die nach etwas
streben was nicht normal ist ja was
außerhalb der mehrheitsgesellschaft
steht und das ist etwas was mich
interessiert und was mir erst mal
grundsätzlich imponiert dass wenn jemand
das markt auch wenn jemand die energie
aufbringt etwas zu machen von dem eben
90 prozent der menschen sagen dass doch
sinnlos
darum sollte man das machen so hat man
früher über die künstler gesprochen die
die schwarze vertraute gepinselt haben
ja warum malt diese menschen schwarze
quadrate was soll das ein dreieck vor
grünem hintergrund so gut das wird
interessant auch so einen affront und
protest gegen diese instrumentelle
vernunft das alles ein zweck abschluss
aber andererseits zieht man an
bodybuilding auch das sozusagen die
optimierung wenn man sie übertreibt
dann kann sie ja gekippten ins ins
gegenteil man kann sich kaum noch
bewegen man kann überhaupt nichts mehr
machen genau also da könnten wir
philosophisch gesprochen mit engel sagen
irgendwann kippt eben quantität in
qualität also wenn ich mich zu sehr
optimieren wenn ich zu viel trainiere
dann erreiche ich ja genau das gegenteil
von dem was vielleicht ursprünglich mal
meine intention gewesen ist und das ist
ganz interessant weil das verweist auf
unseren begriffen normalität
fitnesstraining selbst formung
selbstinszenierung das ist heute normal
bodybuilder gelten allerdings als nicht
normal
dabei machen sie eigentlich nichts
anderes als das was wir alle wie machen
wir arbeiten alle ein bisschen an uns
wie inszenieren uns wir drapieren die
haare
wir gehen ein bisschen ins schwimmen
oder zum kieser training oder ins yoga
die bodybuilder machen das gleiche aber
sie machen es exzessiv und guernsey wenn
ich das steigere conti motiv steigere
erzeugt ist eine neue qualität und sehen
sie diese bewegung auch in anderen
gesellschaftlichen bereichen heute wo
die optimierung des dies funktionale
absolut ernährung ist das beste beispiel
das meiste was heute über ernährung
verzapft wird jetzt mal außerhalb der
wissenschaft ist eigentlich gute
esoterik also wenn ich beginne mich 50
prozent meines lebens mit ernährung zu
befassen welche super food ich jetzt
noch ausprobieren sollte und welche
seltene grünkohl sollte mein leben um
zwölf minuten verlängert dann ist das
für mich etwas etwas dysfunktional es
eine einbuße an lebensqualität und eben
hochgradig esoterisch denn wir wissen ja
gar nicht wie der körper genau auf
welche nahrungsmittel reagiert also mein
individueller körper ob die stoffe
wirken
so aufgenommen werden die
bioverfügbarkeit all das ist überhaupt
nicht geklärte körpers unendlich komplex
und also gerade mit blick auf ernährung
finde ich da heute eine wahnsinnige dies
funktionalität wo es eben gibt ja us ins
gegenteil des angestrebten wo sehen sie
die ursachen dieses ernährungs hypes
dieses dieser fixierung auf ernährung
da würde ich tatsächlich sagen da fehlt
vielleicht ein anderes in horizont also
wenn ich ein projekt habe wenn ich eine
idee habe wenig ein anliegen habe dass
wir sehr sehr wichtig ist für das ich
tatsächlich bereit nach opfer zu bringen
dann fahre ich vielleicht eben mein
super food konsum ein bisschen er zurück
um mich diesem ernsten anliegen zu
bitten wenn ich aber solche anliegen gar
nicht er habe und was ich komplett auf
mich selbst zurückgeworfen bin das ist
ja eigentlich das ist wohl ein
schreckens mission des neoliberalismus
dann habe ich eben nur noch mich selbst
wenn ich mal meinen job mein
wohlbefinden und das ist etwas was ja
das würde ich und auch gesellschaftlich
dysfunktional laufen dass es ethisch ist
wenn es moralisch motiviert ist wieder
was anderes als wenn ich erzähle ich
dann vegan werde ausländisch ist hier
viel schutz ist uns heute das einander
dimensionen wenn es nur noch um mich um
meine gesundheit geht wenn es mir nur
noch darum geht fünf oder zehn jahre
älter zu werden
warum denn wenn ich gar nicht weiß wofür
man hat wirklich den eindruck der körper
ist den neoliberalismus angekommen ich
würde interessieren also müssen
geschichtlich zurückzugehen anders
angefangen hat dass man sozusagen ein
dass der fiete körper ein symbol war für
die leistungsfähigkeit für den
arbeitsmarkt und wo man hat das begonnen
da gibt es sehr interessante und
erhellende studien von vanessas -
amerikanische historiker der
diagnostiziert hat das so um das jahr
1900 herum sich in amerika etwas
verändert hat nämlich die abkehr von dem
was er culture of character die kultur
des charakters genannt hat hin zu einer
culture of professionelle team
kultur der persönlichkeit der charakter
verweist auf das innere auf was sie
meine moralische einstellung meine
haltung sitz am kite und so weiter
wohingegen die personelle die die person
es kommt von der griechischen persona
ist die maske die ich trage person heißt
die maske und dass man sagt in der
jüngeren kapitalistischen ökonomie zählt
vor allem so diese salesman
professionelle team offen sein
cool sein gut rüberzukommen kommunikativ
zu sein und im zuge dieser verlagerung
der aufmerksame aufmerksamkeit hin zur
cult of personality würde ich sagen ist
auch der körper in den fokus gerückt das
heißt wenn ich fit und dynamisch
rüberkommen dann nimmt man mir
vielleicht ab dass ich fit dynamisch ein
unternehmen lenkt er das ich eben die
wir vorher schon gesagt haben belastbar
bin unsere und sofort also das scheint
mir so von ökonomischen
hintergrundrauschen ein wichtiger faktor
zu sein
ein weiterer wichtiger faktor ist die
anglo amerikanische popkultur der körper
zentrierte kultur ist muss es auch darum
geht eben sich zu exponieren auch den
körper zu feiern die körperlichkeit zu
feiern
also erstmal was was positives und da
waren sie die 60er und 70er jahre
ausschlaggebend ist hier macht einen
seite die neue bewegungen dieser gegen
kulturell sind wo es auch befreit der
körperlichkeit also diese hippie zeit
war hippen sei absolut die sich dann
aber verbunden hat mit der
kapitalistischen ökonomie und fiel auch
von dem gegen kulturellen ja ist
eingeflossen in die in die heutige
wirtschaft hin zu dem was soziologen
ragwitz die gesellschaft der
singularitäten nimmt also dass es darum
geht jeder kuratiert sein leben
inszeniert sich als etwas einzigartiges
in social media
beispielsweise und ich hab da all das
kommt zusammen und all das hat den
körper zu etwas was sie wichtigen
gemacht als eine visitenkarte des selbst
ich glaube es war gab jede klein die
einmal diesen schönen begriff gebraucht
hat visitenkarte dass selbst der das
sieht man auch bei amerikanischen
präsidenten das spiel wenn man ronald
reagan in den 80er jahren
wir haben hier das bild als auch als
visitenkarte seiner politischen
kompetenzen wahrscheinlich ganz genau
also dass es eben es ist performance
nicht ja dieser mann performt arnold
schwarzenegger hat er viel von dragon
kopiert hat viel von ihm aufgegriffen
und weiterentwickelt und auch seine
politik war eigentlich eine politik
eigentlich ist eines freundlichen
populismus
wo es um so getting things done ging
also was sie kräftig tatkräftig
dynamisch etwas zu tun und regen hat es
in den 80er jahren einig antizipiert da
sieht man auch nicht also im gesicht des
gesichts design der amerikanischen
präsidenten ist ja ganz interessant auch
da also drei bis fünf tage werde es
werden noch bis heute für amerikanische
präsidenten
also das ist quasi frisch dynamisch jung
offen westlich frei das sind diese
glatten gesichter und dazu kommt dann im
idealfall noch nicht fitten körper in
amerika es ist ja üblich dass die
ergebnisse der gesundheits checks der
präsidenten veröffentlicht werden so
dass das volk weiß haben unser präsident
ist körperlich in der lage sein job zu
machen zumindest gehört weil ich gegen
trainiert hier an einer maschine dieses
symbolik von maschinen maschine und
mensch wie viel trans humanistisches
steckt denn eigentlich in diesem
fitnesstraining dringen wie viel wunsch
selbst zu einer maschine zu werden oder
zu etwas besser als nur ein mensch ja ja
ich würde sagen da steckt ziemlich viel
post und trans humanistisches drin
es beginnt so in der zweiten hälfte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts dass menschen
an maschinen trainieren
anfänglich noch aus therapeutischen
medizinischen gründen später dann aus
effizienzgründen also die maschine
ermöglicht es mir einfach sehr viel
schneller und auch sicherer
welche muskelmasse aufzubauen und was
jetzt im fitnessstudio passiert ist ja
so eine art verschmelzung von mensch und
maschine zumindest temporär was menschen
spannen sich in maschinen ein arbeiten
quasi mit maschinen zusammen um selbst
zu wachsen um sich zu transformieren und
für mich sind das einige lektionen in
demut
also man sieht dass man was sie
eigentlich nur mit hilfe der maschine in
der lage ist es so und so schnell diese
und jene resultate zu erzielen und diese
quasi diese ähnlichkeit von mensch und
maschine die sich da im studio 1 stellt
die ist glaube ich sehr bezeichnend für
eine phase noch bisschen vor dem
neoliberalismus bevor das so eine große
geschichte wurde weil was macht die
maschine die maschine führt uns sie
stützt uns sie hilft uns einig also ich
hab die trainingsmaschinen mal als
sozialstaat bezeichnet also das ist ein
gelenk das eingeführtes training wo uns
sie viel arbeit auch abgenommen wird und
wo vor allem das risiko minimiert wird
ja das verletzungsrisiko an maschinen
ist sehr viel geringer als das
verletzungsrisiko im teamsport im
wettbewerbsorientierten sport und
training mit freien gewichten okay also
insofern sehen wir da eigentlich ist
auch eine symbolische konstellation der
menschen arbeiten mit maschinen zusammen
um über sich hinauszuwachsen
die maschine als sozia auf start ja aber
es gibt ja jetzt habe ich seit einigen
jahren auch einen gegentrend hinter
diesem functional training wo man eben
ohne maschinen trainiert und sondern so
lebensnah übungen gemacht wegen
kniebeugen klingt züge rennen
muss man das drücken in der tat ist es
so dass sich das klassische bodybuilding
auf dem rückzug ist also das klassische
maschinen training sogar den 80er 90er
sind die frühen nullerjahre eine sehr
angesagt ist das gesamte kieser training
büro beruht weiterhin auf maschinen
training zurzeit erleben einen boom des
sogenannten functional trainings und da
würde ich tatsächlich sagen das passt
gut zu dem was als risiko gesellschaft
bezeichnet worden ist
also es geht darum dass ich wieder frei
trainiere übungen mache die skills
kompetenzen erfordern wo ich mir aber
was reißen kann oder was brechen kann
und wo ich vor allem auch mit dem
eigenen körpergewicht arbeit als ich
arbeite nicht mehr für sie gegen den
widerstand der maschine nicht mehr gegen
den widerstand des eisens ich arbeite
nicht gegen etwas anderes gegen etwas
nicht menschliches sondern ich arbeite
an und mit und gegen mich selbst und das
passt ja durchaus gut zu diesem narrativ
sei für dich selbst verantwortlich
kümmere dich um dich selbst und gehe
auch risiken ein
das da scheint mir das fand training gut
rein zu bleiben flexibel ganz bereitet
sich vor auf das ungewisse ganz
wichtiger punkt
die maschine steht eben an einem
bestimmten ort ich muss zum gehen wie
ich in die kirche gehen muss nicht die
kirche kommt nicht zu mir
der alltag kommt nicht zu mir und die
beiden presse kommen das heißt diese
mobilität sein stichwort und eben beim
franzel training ist solch ein training
das ich überall machen kann und das ist
zumindest die idee dahinter ich habe
kurz zeigt in der mittagspause zackig
gehen stadtpark und ich trainiere dort
für das alte maschinen training hat man
sie wissen was was trägers und auch was
die verwurzeltes functional training an
jim hat es nicht mehr am flughafen bin
habe ich im park bin im büro bin überall
soll trainiert werden können
gleichzeitig ist das auch wenn
retro trend das ist so wie die
steinzeitmenschen irgendwie sich zu
haben
da gibt es wir haben über eine ernährung
schon gesprochen und es gibt diese
herrstein zeit jeden rohkost und so es
gibt auch was den körper angeht diesen
starken retro-trend ist es so etwas wie
eine vorbereitung auf den kommenden
weltuntergang das ist jetzt wie stärkt
und unabhängig was gar nicht so abwegig
glaube ich also da ist durchaus ist
vielleicht ein bisschen apocalyptic und
angst drin in diesen trends es geht ja
von den übungen wenn man sie es genau
anguckt es geht zurück ins frühe 19
jahrhundert es sind wieder die übungen
von turnvater jahn turnvater jahn hat in
deutschland um 1800 die deutschen ja für
den kampf gegen die franzosen trainiert
ton plätze gegründet und die übungen die
damals was ich gepflegt worden wie man
damals trainiert hat das kommt zurzeit
wieder zurück was auch medizinbälle zum
beispiel das urwüchsiges trainingsgerät
ist alles wieder da
und insofern halte ich das gar nicht für
für abwegig zu sagen ja das rüsten sich
menschen wieder für welche kämpfe auch
immer also ich bin kirchgängern ich gehe
ins team
ich möchte ins gym gehen ich trainiere
an maschinen das ist mir sehr nahe
auch dieses postel trans humanistische
element das ist mir sehr wichtig und
dieses dieses freie
anwendungsorientierte bisschen
paramilitärische das sehe ich mit einer
gewissen skepsis
was ja auch gerade sind ist unser boot
camp artige trainings konstellation wo
dann ein trainer eine gruppe trainiert
eben ich sehe dass morgens in
pfingstweid park beispielsweise wenn ich
zur arbeit gehe
steht der typ vorne und feuert an und
brüllt auch ein bisschen rum und dann
wird etwas in der gruppe exerziert
bodybuilding ist ja klassischerweise
eigentlich ein individualtraining also
menschen tatsächlich auch durch alleine
trainieren können henry rollins musiker
kraftsportler das immer betont prefer to
work out also dieses zurückgeworfen
seien auf sich selbst das ist eigentlich
etwas was mir selber sehr wichtig sie
sind ja auch bodybuilder und musiker ich
hab das schon höher getönt in der
anmoderation also sie sind heavy metal
musiker seit längerer zeit haben eine
band oder ein duo das heißt mahlzeit sie
beschäftigen sich aber auch sagen
kognitiv geistig mit mit dem heavy metal
aber wir möchten uns trotzdem nur ganz
kurz anhören wie das so klingt wenn sie
auf der bühne sind
[Musik]
das nicht so
und
noch dicker
ja heavy metal mit hemd im sitzen guten
viel ironie steckt im ganzen also mir
ist es ja immer ernst mit der ehrung in
der er olic eine haltung zur ironie sagt
ich weiß dass sie dinge auch anders sein
könnten
ich sehe da eine differenz also ich
komme da stark als der frühromantischen
ironie raus wenn sie sowohl das müssen
sie kurz erläutern die ersten
frühromantiker war es ja so dass man
gesagt hat dass ganz kurz
zusammenzufassen
man kann die welt eben auch anders sehen
also es ist nicht alles in stein
gemeißelt und wenn ich etwas ironisch
tue dann tue ich etwas meine es aber
anders
also ich mache etwas ganz ganz betont
ernsthaft dabei ist es eigentlich lustig
gemeint und umgekehrt
und das ist eigentlich ein gestus der
freiheit also ich fast klar für mich
nicht einen bestimmten code einem
bestimmten zeichensystem wo jedes
zeichen ganz klar eine bedeutung
gekoppelt ist sondern ironie ist
eigentlich erst mal eine geste der
freiheit und bei meiner zeit war das
eigentlich ist so dass wir gesagt haben
wir lieben heavy metal also dass die
musik mit der wir aufgewachsen sind ich
habe meine erste metal band und lade ich
bin mit 13 jahren in die erste metal
band eingetreten stand mit 14 jahren zum
ersten mal auf bühnen und ist die musik
die mir sehr nahe ist und es ist eine
hassliebe wenn sie so wollen natürlich
ist heavy metal klischeehaft und es ist
peinlich und es ist sowohl der top und
die gesten sind immer ein bisschen zu
groß für das was eigentlich da ist aber
gleichzeitig finde ich man kann ja
eigentlich nur dinge lieben die irgendwo
ein bisschen gebrochen sind man kann
dinge nur auf ironische art und weise
lieben mann liebt etwas obwohl es auch
so und so ist wie man auch menschen
liebt dann sagte man liebt sie nicht
vollumfänglich für alle sondern weil sie
das haben und das andere ist eben auch
noch daran so ist beim heavy metal auch
was mir mit meinem zeit einige versuchen
könnte man als sie vom vom endt
körperlichen das mittel bezeichnet also
mittel ist ein sehr körper orientierte
form der popmusik geht es eben es geht
um kraft es geht um macht es geht um
selbstermächtigung es geht auch darum
dass sie in diesem dieser in dieser lärm
wand zu bestehen das verbindet das auch
müssen mit dem bodybuilding und dann
stellt diesen körperkult oder wie das
ist die idee die die die größe der gäste
auch quasi dieser versuch eben einer
großen belastung standzuhalten
also sie unter dem gewicht stand zu
halten und vor den marshall boxen die
bestialische lautstärke ist da stand zu
halten
das wäre dann heavy metal was mit meinem
zeit machen ist wir setzen uns hin
also wir setzen uns zum metal spielen
auf eine couch wir trinken aus porzellan
tässchen tee am besten aus organischem
anbau alle texte dieser songs die wir
spielen das ist ein ereignis die handeln
vom wetter es war uns ganz wichtig weil
die anderen beiden großen themen des
heavy metal also sex und tod die sind ja
schon hinreichend behandelt lässt sich
nicht mehr viel hinzuzufügen hinzufügen
aber das wetter also das dritte große
thema das uns alle betrifft und alle
verbindet ist einstreifig vernachlässigt
worden im mittel also sind über das
wetter man versteht es nicht wirklich
weil geschrieben wird und ist natürlich
auch meistens schlechtes wetter aber
grundsätzlich ist es eine ein versuch
quasi diese aufdringliche körperlichkeit
das mittel
manche würden sie als aufdringlich
empfinden zurückzufahren und eine form
von metal zu machen die tatsächlich
ironisch gebrochen ist aber die ernst
gemeint ist also das ist nicht einfach
ein gag oder den witz wir veralbern
heavy metal nicht sondern wir bringen
den auf eine farm wo wir sagen ja das
sind ein paar klischees weniger und das
beste mittel bleibt ja und das ist
bezeichnend für das was sie eigentlich
immer auch tun
in der forschung also sie unterscheiden
nicht zwischen hochkultur und popkultur
sondern sie irgendwie beackern alle
felder und schreiben zum beispiel auch
über über werte und gesichtsbehaarung
und intim behaarung aus kunsthistoriker
etwa dieses buch hier ähnlich groß dem
schönen titel jetzt haben wir viel über
muskeln gesprochen über körperkult und
es gibt ja noch andere trends diese
diese gibbs der werte zb die sieht man
plötzlich seit einigen jahren wir haben
jemand zwei beispiele ausgesucht von
ganz unterschiedlichen endmärkten
vielleicht können sie kurz sagen woher
dieser bat trend eigentlich kommt wie
sie den deutsch ja der bauten das buch
das wir herausgegeben haben eine von
gross war nicht nur eine reaktion also
in der form von was intellektueller
notwehr auf den bart trend weil wir alle
wissen seit zehn zwanzig jahren grob der
bart eine fulminante renaissance erlebt
hat und wir irgendwas gefühl hatten ja
alle tag mit smart aber niemand fragt
warum wir haben uns gefragt wo kommen
eine spezifische barth typen her was
bedeuten bestimmte die partie
chronographen wenn man so will
was ist der unterschied hinsichtlich
bedeutung eines freibads wir ihn hier
sehen oder eines hipster sie werden auf
der anderen seite sehen vereinfacht
senkte bedeutung geben also um die frage
kurz zurück zu kommen wo kommt das
eigentlich her ich glaube es hat viel
mit identitätspolitik zu tun also mit
dem bedürfnis wieder eine identität
auszudrücken der bart ist ein sehr
starker identitäts marke sehr präsent er
ist eben im gesicht ist anders als ein
tattoo auf dem oberarm das oft verdeckt
ist oder eine beeindruckende
bauchmuskulatur die man zumindest in
unseren breitengraden nicht ständig
sieht also gepaart ist sehr sehr
kompetent
er hat sicherlich etwas damit zu tun
dass es ein neues bedürfnis ergibt dass
die männlichkeit auszudrücken sogar sie
einzelne letzten merkmale was männer
frauen unterscheidet von den meisten
zumindest also glaubt identität ist ein
wichtiges ist ein wichtiges stichwort
und ansonsten glaube ich hat das auch
viel damit zu tun dass wir in so
multipolaren zeiten heute leben wenn man
es ein bisschen herunterbricht könnte
man sagen eigentlich bis um das jahr
1990 herum gab es so eine relativ klare
aufgabenteilung der besten war
weitestgehend bartlos also die
amerikanischen präsidenten hatten wir
erwähnt sie signalisieren ihre
modernität durch bad losigkeit der papst
in rom ist bald los das ist quasi die
katholische moderne wenn man so will
orthodoxe priester im osten hingegen
tagen rauschebart diktatoren tagen
eigentlich immer werte also das war so
die ungefähre aufgabenteilung einig in
der zeit in der die welt bipolar
organisiert war aufgrund des binären
codes fortschrittlich westlich liberal
das war großes bad lose oder mit ein
paar kleinen ironischen bärtchen und auf
der anderen seite quasi das ist das
urwüchsige hre traditionelleren und
diese bipolare oder binäre ordnung ist
wie wir alle wissen aufgebrochen
neben in der hybriden übergangszeit und
insofern überrascht es nicht dass in
dieser hybriden übergangszeit eben auch
die berge zurück gekommen sind als eine
selbst gestaltungs option unter vielen
anderen auch
einerseits dieses hybride spiegelt sich
darin dass ein bart etwas urwüchsiges
ist aber gleichzeitig ist der heute sehr
gepflegt es gibt viele pflegeprodukte
wie diesen praxis unter weiter also es
ist einerseits wieder dieses retro oder
dieses ursprüngliche männliche
vielleicht auch aber dann auch zu zeigen
ich lege mich nicht mehr zeit für meinen
körper uns genau
also das ist ja eigentlich ein
charakterzug der westlichen moderne jede
modernisierungs bewegung war immer mit
einem
ganz gezielt ein rückgriff auf ältere
vorbilder verbunden und insofern kann
ich vielleicht durch den bart heute wie
dialektisch meine modernität betonen was
ich tragen anzug oder eine sehr
ausgefallene outfit mit diesen
urwüchsigen restbestand so damit hat
sich einig etwas ins gegenteil verkehrt
was über viele jahrhunderte und
jahrtausende gängig war nämlich die
oberschicht hat sich rasiert die
oberschicht das waren die rasierten die
aristokraten die patrizier die hatten
die zeit die hatten die mittel und die
die sich nicht rasieren konnten das war
die weniger privilegierten wir hatten
überhaupt nicht die möglichkeit erst mit
der erfindung von sicherheits
rasierklingen war es überhaupt möglich
dass sich breite bevölkerungsschichten
rasieren und heute hat sich das
eigentlich ins gegenteil verkehrt ich
kann meine modernität ja meine fitness
eben durch den bart ausdrücken und auch
einen gewissen status ja durch den bart
wohingegen eben früher sie dass sie die
die rasur eigentlich ein statussymbol
und heute ist es aufwendige einen
gepflegten bart zu tragen also alles
ganz genau was bedeutet eigentlich ihr
kleiner bad hier an der unterlippe
das ist so ein alibi bärtchen der zeit
lang auch sieben bart getragen und so
weiter aber in der von abgerückt der
trend auch genervt hat das ist ein dizzy
gillespie war das ist eigentlich ein
jazz bad was sie das stammt wurde
geprägt von dizzy gillespie jazzmusiker
und wenn man sich diesen bart in der
jazz geschichte anschaut dann sieht man
eher markiert einig den übergang vom
süßlichen swing zum bebop und bebop ist
mir im jazzbereich sehr nahe und
insofern habe ich mich für diesen dizzy
gillespie hat entschieden
auch natürlich weil er sehr unaufwendig
ist ja es gibt ein fantastisches
interview mit viele castor zu sein bart
befragt wird und er sagt neuer also
sinngemäß die revolution wäre vielleicht
nicht so erfolgreich gewesen wenn ich zu
viel zeit für meine bank
er verwendet hätte also hat er diesen
diesen eher wuchernden bart gehabt und
da sieht man nicht er hat sein leben in
den dienst der revolution gestellt und
deswegen sind pflege und zum rasieren
gekommen ja wie rasieren uns ja heute
schon auch die männer
viele davon nämlich irgendwie an der
brust intimbereich und so weiter ein
riesen trend was kann man darüber sagen
dass das eine sehnsucht nach
jugendlichkeit zurück oder was was
passiert da es wurde ja schon sehr viel
darüber gesagt dass die am stärksten
verbreitete these ist allgemeine
pornografisierung hat vor allem jahren
mal eine andere these aufgestellt
spekulativ ist aber es ist zumindest
bedenkenswert nämlich dahingehend dass
diese rasierten körper eigentlich post
historische körper sind sie passen einig
zu dieser diagnose die francis fukuyama
im übergang 80er jahre zu 90 jahren
aufgestellt hat der amerikanische
politik wiederum da der abschwung zu
gast war ich würde ja dass wir einig was
sie ein ende der geschichte erleben ja
also die geschichte ist irgendwo zu
einem zum innehalten gekommen
liberalismus kapitalismus demokratie das
war sehr gibt es nicht das genügt auch
dieser körper passt diese enthalten ist
eine zeitlose körper ist quasi an den
perlt alles ab dessen teflon körper
teflon körper die sind quasi derzeit den
fährnissen der zeit entrückt es in eine
himmlische körper wenn sie so wollen
es sind die körper von der antiken
statuen und sie so wollen es sind die
körper von engeln wenn sie so wollen
uwe hat die körper von pornodarstellern
genau muss man schon weil es immer dass
jetzt auch über die pornodarsteller
engel und den himmel aus sagt nein aber
ich wollte einfach diese dimension und
auch mit in dem diskurs bringt das wenn
sie in die
die theologie schauen gibt es natürlich
dieses versprechen mit dabei thomas von
aquin dem solistischen theologen des
mittelalters dass wenn wir gut gelebt
haben und dann ins jenseits bekommen
perfekte körper haben wir haben immer
noch körper also es gibt die
auferstehung des fleisches
aber das werde neben körper sein die
nicht mehr altern das werden körper sein
die sie nicht mehr vermehren müssen es
sind körper die nicht mehr essen müssen
und so ich stelle mir diese körper ist
so ähnlich vor wie diese ganz ganz ganz
körper enthalten die wir heute haben und
vielleicht ist es auch seine crypto
theologische clubtour religiöse
dimension die damit die da mit rein
spielt aber dazu passen ja nicht die
tattoos die auch sehr verbreitet sind
baut es wieder frühling man wird zu
übersehen
ein unglaublicher trend also ja ich weiß
nicht wie viele kennt die statistiken
nick nicht aber sie ist sehr viele
personen tragen tattoos und das ist ja
eigentlich eine verletzung dieser
reinheit ihres körpers absolut keine
anekdote erzählen in diesem zusammenhang
ist es schon einmal passiert dass ich im
fitness center unter der dusche stand
ein anderer kam rein mich angeguckt und
hat gesagt krass kein tattoo als man
fällt manchmal schon auf weil man nicht
tätowiert ist es begründungspflicht ich
nicht tätowiert zu sein
es erzeugt eine gewisse irritation aber
ist eine bild wissenschaftlichen sicht
könnte man spekulieren auch dass eine
spekulation dass die bildproduktion
vermutlich am eigenen körper begonnen
hat irgendwo in grauer vorzeit also dass
menschen begonnen haben das spiel haut
zu bemalen status zu markieren durch
tattoo ähnliche fordern höhlenmalereien
körperbemalung
das ist eine bild anthropologische these
die durchaus eine gewisse plausibilität
hat dass ich im laufe der geschichte was
ich die bilder vom körper immer weiter
weg zb an die höhen band irgendwann an
die museumswand und
in den ferien sehr verlagert haben also
die bewegung ist tatsächlich das bild
entfernt sich vom körper und was wir
jetzt sehen was ich seit dem 19
jahrhundert beobachten können ist die
rückkehr der bilder auf den körper also
19 jahrhundert beginnt man was im
fitnesscenter zu trainieren also sich
selbst zu bild zur skulptur zu formen
und im zuge dessen was der
medientheoretiker marshall mcluhan der
global village genannt hat also das
zusammenwachsen der welt zu einem
globalen dorf kehren auch die
körperbemalungen kehren die tattoos
zurück auf den körper wir markieren
status wir markieren identität direkt
auf den körper haben als man früher mit
mit moden gemacht hat oder mit trachten
mit applikationen
all das kommt jetzt direkt auf den
körper und ich glaube da gibt es ein
großes bedürfnis tatsächlich nach
körperlicher präsenz was wir am anfang
angesprochen wir hatten nach etwas
konkretem etwas spürbaren etwas was uns
ganz nahe ist also das bild soll nicht
mehr so weit weg sein von mir das
zeichnen soll nicht mehr nur da draußen
sein sondern es soll nahe bei mir sein
also vielleicht geht es auch darum umso
eine wiederum zurück erlangung der
kontrolle
ich habe das bild bei mir der wand das
kann nicht abbrennen oder verloren gehen
es ist da aber andere bilder versenden
wie in die ganze welt absolut nämlich
die selbst die wir machen von uns von
gesichtern vom körper
wir schauen da mal ganz kurz ein damit
wir so ein bisschen spüren was da abgeht
mit diesen service und mit diesen also
wenn man auf diesen sozialen medien
unterwegs ist oder instagram und so
diese bilderflut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier kam noch die schönheitsoperation
also dieses mittags mit den spieler
werden ein eigenes thema aber was sagt
der kunsthistoriker zu dieser flut an
service und selbstdarstellung nehmen
jetzt also es wird ja gerne belächelt
wie sie vorher schon gesagt haben ich
differenziere zwar durchaus zwischen
high und low aber jetzt nicht zwischen
reiner unterhaltungskultur und rainer
hochkultur
ich würde dieselbe kultur durchaus als
eine ernstzunehmende kultur betrachten
wo es eigentlich erst mal darum geht
sich in eine allgemeine bildsprache
einzuschreiben
kunsthistoriker wolfgang ullrich hat
bereits von service als einem neuen welt
sprache gesprochen also dass die globale
bild kultur entstanden an der ich durch
das einfügen durch das produzieren von
self anteil habe
das ist erstmal eine relativ
demokratische geschichte wie auch immer
man die bewertet ob man die für
originell und relevant wurde was auch
immer erachtet aber es ist eine globale
bewegung und ich glaube es geht gar
nicht so sehr um das selbst im tv
sondern es geht eigentlich darum teil
dieses ganzen zu werden also teil einer
sehr viel kultur zu werden weil das l4
ist ja erst mal als alfie erkennbar und
dann erst quasi sieht man das selbst auf
dem cl-finale sagen erstmals 11 naja es
ist für mich steckt da schon viel
nazismus dahinter und auch viele
gefahren eben wenn man wenn diese
optimierten selbst bilder zu normen
darunter leiden auch viele jugendliche
absolut also im originell ist das ganze
nicht wirklich oder das ist immer die
gleiche distanz ist die gleiche apparate
auf der anderen seite gibt es natürlich
auch avantgarden im self bereich es gibt
leute die andere self es aufnehmen
es gibt leute
dies erwies kommentieren sich darüber
gedanken machen ich glaube das ist so
wenn man es jetzt historisch betrachtet
das ist eine neue salonkultur der wird
bei seine form von homogenität erzeugt
da wird eine form von normalität erzeugt
wie es immer schon der fall war in
irgendwelchen bild kulturen in
öffentlichen kultur und optimierte
normalität die affen druck gesetzt für
viele wobei bei dem service bin ich gar
nicht so sicher ob es da tatsächlich um
optimierung geht weil sie elf zwischen
casual format also das kann man flüchtig
machen
dafür muss ich mich nicht perfektioniert
haben ich stelle mich nicht zu nicht
zwingend ewig sondern es werden auch
ganz weil sie kurz spontan mal
aufgenommen und und gepostet
ich würde immer differenzieren es gibt
innerhalb dessen kultur
doch eben wieder eine hochkultur wenn
sie so wollen und es gibt was ihre form
von spielerischer cash for culture
könnte man es nennen
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ich
das ganze ausdifferenziert es beginnt
immer mit diesen normalisierung
versuchen homogenisierung versuchen dann
gibt es welche die brechen aus die form
subkulturen und tatsächlich glaube
dieser narzissmus hat nicht so viel mit
selbst zu tun als es eigentlich ein
selbstloser narzissmus denn es ist nicht
wahnsinnig originell ich inszeniere mich
nicht selbst und das self wie wird
eigentlich erst dann ins elfi wenn es in
sich in dieser digitalen zirkulation
ströme einspeisen lässt davor nimmt
niemand auf dem kenntnis letzte frage
herrsche ja sie sind eine sehr
vielfältige persönlichkeit wie wir
gesehen haben sie sind professor
muskelprotz zumindest teilzeit
bodybuilder zeigt wo die bilder lassen
heavy metal musiker publizist wenn sie
einen self machen müssten von sich was
wäre darauf zu sehen damit ihre person
am treffen system abgebildet ist ich
habe vor einiger zeit eine serie gemacht
auf twitter die hieß 11 lassie und das
waren einfach selbst die ich von mir
aufgenommen habe aber immer am kopf
vorbei foto gerät also ich habe mich vor
irgendwelchen dingen fotografiert und
immer ganz genau hier vorbei da steht
dass sie die alles jahr für mich sehr
schön hersteller vielen herzlichen dank
für diese stunde dankeschön
ja danke ihnen fürs mit denk nächste
woche spricht barbara bleisch mit helene
klar der meist gefürchteten
scheidungsanwältin österreichs die meint
besser eine ehe ohne liebe als eine
scheidung ohne geld und jetzt gleich
gibt es kunst hoch 2 1 4 porträt zweier
künstler diesmal über den schriftsteller
thomas mayer und den filmemacher michael
steiner bleiben sie also dran uns einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]
hallo